the Pennsylvania House representatives
passed an amendment saying that marriage
is between one man and one woman and
anything similar to marriage would not
count so that's the part that gets rid
of the domestic partnership civil unions
common law marriage anything like that
it went down to the principal Senate and
they passed it but they took out that
second stipulation so they only said
between one man and one woman because
they didn't pass the same amendment they
can't put this on vote this can't pass
until both groups agree on the wording
so right now it's stuck while it's stuck
we have an opportunity to discuss it to
research it find out all the different
things that entails and really get
people from the state from our local
universities talking about it and find
out what their opinions are find out how
they feel how they feel after they've
discussed it after they've been educated
on it so that by the time we're done
with our entire program the process this
is only the beginning of it but once
we're done with everything we can
actually go up the policymakers and say
look here's what we've done we've
educated people we've let them talk
about it and here's what their opinions
are these are the people you voted for
you these are people you represent
listen to them people get notices about
the event they register for it and then
at the point of registration they get a
background document it's been very
carefully prepared on the issue they
read that they fill out a you know a
short survey and then on the day of the
event they come here here the first
thing they do is they're going to fill
out a pre survey just their initial
opinions before they've gone through the
process so we have a way of you know
comparing that to their opinions after
the process they do that they're going
to go into the auditorium for an
introductory session where dr. Robert
Cavalier Jay divine and a few other
people are going to give brief remarks
and then they're going to split into the
small groups those small groups with a
very focused discussion where people
talk about the issue go through points
from the background document and at the
end of that they'll prepare a couple
questions they then I'll meet together
back in the auditorium where they'll
have the opportunity to ask those
questions too
expert panel a resource panel people
that are very well versed in the field
from you no legal religious societal
stick point of view and they'll the
opportunity to ask those questions after
that they then return to the small
groups process the information and then
finally fill out a final survey saying
what they thought about the process how
their opinions have changed if they have
what understandings have been broadened
etc etc for me I think that marriage is
a very personal decision and as long as
it does not harm someone like an
individual or the society I don't think
the state has any any business to
regulate it as long as it's between two
consenting adults I don't think the
state has a sane and and as far as the
religious conflict goes again here again
have I come from a religious background
with marriage is not exactly a religious
thing it's more for social thing so in
that sense I have a little bit of
difficulty getting into the whole church
versus the law aspect of thing if a law
is being made about marriage then then
it shouldn't be based on religion
because then you're just thinking about
maybe one religion or whatever the
majority religion is a civil marriage is
still I think about Trenton about
anything but separate from anything I
think I agree with you and I will get
religion is more of a social journey I
think that well no I know from my
personal experience many people who have
married for reasons other than romantic
attraction
or to have children I have known people
who have married to have children I have
no people for social reasons who
admitted for social reasons I've known
people who would marry for monetary
reasons people who have married to keep
one of the partners in the country so
there are any matter of things I think
they're different all sorts of different
criteria of why people choose to be
together I would have thought that civil
union is a fine that and it pointed out
to me that it really is creating with
that separate biblical status so that
was really enlightening to me you know i
thought well yes so may be fine
believing as i do that marriage
recognized by the state and marriage
recognized by the religious organization
should be sadly I have European friends
and they get married both ways they go
down to the town hall and they register
and then they walk down the street to
the church and they get married and so
it's two separate entities would I have
a problem with when I was reading this
was just changing the whole definition
of marriage between you know one man and
one woman just changing the definition
all together and I don't know I don't
feel comfortable which I you know okay
what they do I mean 50 every hundred
years we change the definition of
marriage to suit a particular group I
don't know and one of the supplemental
readings the man pointed out that it
would be nice and if it wasn't just like
a special interest but if it would just
be like let's improve economic benefits
for everybody let's improve health
benefits for everybody
generally all the energy into the
homosexual world versus the heterosexual
because I'm a single person and I feel
like a lot of times that okay because
I'm single well life isn't fair like you
know tax codes and things don't benefit
me in any way shape or form but I'm not
asking for people to change the
definition or to say you know make it
you know revise the codes or the laws to
benefit single people like I'm not I'm
not asking people to do that you just
kind of accept it and it's just okay you
know life isn't fair get over it it has
certainly shifted from the merits to
hold tribes together merge the whole
country's together two nerds whole two
people together and I think that our
government being involved in marriage so
deeply and so fundamentally still
reflects the idea marriage as a social
thing as a social contract rather than
marriage is a personal contract I think
that awesome my opinion
every to get intense completely out of
marriage that if two people cared for
each other they should be able to enter
into this personal contract however they
would like to unfortunately because of
the way that our country is and because
of how unlikely it is I think we have to
look at the other place it's not
possible to say that in my lifetime the
government is going to say oh okay you
guys can get married it's no problem
anyone go do it if they like each other
enough it's not something that which be
interference I see the government
and because of that I think it turned
into releasable right at you and I would
like to see it be a civil rights issue
instead of a definition fish here
because when you get to the death we can
really hope buttons that people only
have quote i strongly believe that
religion does play a strong park with
the government and i don't believe in
same sex
especially when you're involving
children and we're speaking about the
bringing of children in this certain
situation my perspective on is it that I
believe the Bible is the words of God
not the Word of God
and I think this idea of government in
the Christian or the judeo-christian
religion being so completely tied
together i think it's very long and i
think it's very dangerous none of it
just boils down to economics is it just
give a word that says it everything is
all inclusive and then everybody's taxes
the same rate and everybody's viewed the
same and everybody would be happy I know
that sounds may be naive or very
elementary but I think maybe think ones
down to the money in you know and like
you know a perceived benefit okay you
are living as though you're in the
marriage we can't prevent you from the
benefits that you can get we can't keep
you from consecrating this thing as you
would like to with a representative from
room 9 please stand
when rod posed nude for my queen please
behavior question we had a question that
was probably directed most towards
Maureen Cohen what are the benefits is
marriage and all of them available I
other legal means and as sort of a
follow-up to that how often are you
creating legal marriage like contracts
are helping people obtain benefits who
are not married thank you I can if I can
answer the second part first just
because I remember we asked that first
part again yes as a lawyer and a family
lawyer I I do domestic partner
agreements or cohabitation agreements
and I do those for same-sex couples
because unless same-sex couples do two
agreements and estate planning and take
proactive measure things will happen at
the time of their hang up for the time
of general that they may not want to
happen so we address issues with regards
to living together separate property
what if the partners break up what
allows to each point if you're not
married you do not just in Pennsylvania
especially there are no database so you
have to take proactive measures to make
sure that company's not able to marry
pretty much as is possible to cover all
the legal benefits that a married couple
would if you are a same-sex couple that
isn't married I think I think you can
maybe not all of them I give seminars
and it talks about what would be what
you can put into a domestic partner
agreement and someone said what if I
just put my partner and I want all the
benefits of law
under the statute for marriage would
that be enforced by a court it's a great
idea that I don't think it'll be
enforced by a court because it'd be a
defense of marriage act if it asked if a
man and a woman can only partake of the
benefits of marriage you can't say they
want every benefit can expect a cord to
give it to you so I don't know that that
you can really that a same-sex couple
can be protected as a varied couple just
because of the laws available or not
thank you your questionable lantern
you did have some time not too late to
fill out that survey just being in this
little environment right now it's hard
not to get kind of charged about it
democracy and civic engagement these
days is so much either partisan shouting
matches or it's you know just you're
very isolated you know in the voting
booth and that's your only engagement
with the democratic process and that's
not how this country was founded in
these little pockets of you know people
getting together and actually doing the
grunt work of democracy is kind of an
exciting opportunity or anything to be a
part and I'm kind of getting a little
bit charged from it right now
you